Let's
go.
the crime of the antichrist. Now, we've
dealt with some of these issues already
yesterday,
but perhaps we just want to put one or
two things into perspective and see
where we're heading. Before I do that,
what is a beast in the Bible?
>> It's a political entity. Now, we find
the beast in Revelation as well. And uh
we find that beast in Revelation 13. And
it rises up out of the sea amongst the
nations. And then it has all the
attributes of the little horn. All the
attributes of the little horn. And we'll
deal with that prophecy in detail. I
think it is tomorrow night. Tomorrow
night. And somebody asked me earlier, is
America in prophecy?
Well, come and listen tomorrow night and
let's have a look what the Bible says
and then you decide for yourself if it's
in there or whether it's not in there. I
mean, this is this is a thunderous time
that we're living in
now. You know, if something walks like a
duck and it looks like a duck and it
quacks like a duck, then it's probably a
duck, right?
So if if something has exactly the same
attributes as the little horn in Daniel
chapter 7, then what is the probability
that it is the little horn in Daniel
chapter 7? Pretty good, right? Okay.
So this power we'll be dealing with
tomorrow night. And there is just so
much to deal with. You cannot open it up
all in one evening. But uh let's have a
look at this little horn power and look
at some of the aspects of what it did.
The little horn power in Daniel 7:25 we
saw last night would think to change
times and laws. Of course, he says that
he can change times and laws. He can
change the times. He can change God's
law. But in actual fact, he only
presumes to. He's presumptuous. Nobody
can change God's law and get away with
it. Would you agree?
>> Remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy. Six days shalt thou labor and do
all thy work. But the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord thy God. And in it
you shall not do any work. Thou, nor thy
son, nor thy daughter, thy manservant,
nor thy baidervant, nor thy cattle, nor
thy stranger, that is within thy gates.
Four, and now there's a reason, in six
days the Lord made the heavens and the
earth. Now, what does the evolution
theory do with that text?
>> Throws it out.
>> Throws it in the waste paper basket. How
many lectures did we spend here saying
that you cannot throw that text into the
waste paper basket? Was it for? I think
so. You cannot throw that in the waste
paper basket. Now, why so much effort to
throw that piece in the waste paper
basket? Because if that piece is not in
the waste paper basket, then you're in
trouble with this one.
The sea and all that in them is and he
rested on the seventh day. Wherefore the
Lord blessed the Sabbath day and
hallowed it. Exodus 28-11. That means he
set it aside for holy use.
Now man was created male and female
representing communication on the
horizontal level. He was to be
confederate.
But without God in the equation, you
have what you have today. Total chaos.
Not only in marriage but in general. You
have to have God in the equation. This
is quite an interesting story. When I
first came into contact with God, I was
actually quite jealous of him
because he requires first place
and I was married to my wife and she was
all mine.
And now I had to share her. That was
tough. I I I walked around with a lip
this long for quite a while while I was
muddling this over. Maybe I'm just a bit
weird, but I was thinking about these
things. Now, eventually when I started
realizing the character of God and his
total selfishness,
if someone is 100% selfless like Jesus
was, he poured himself out for mankind.
If he's 100% selfish, then how much are
you going to get out of the deal if you
are dealing with such an individual?
You're going to get 100%.
And that's the beauty of it. You see, if
you love God supremely,
you get God's love supremely,
unselfishly
poured out upon you. And the blessing
becomes so great that the relationship
between a man and a woman gets
increased
in
relationship glory. Whatever you want to
call it millions of times it gets
enhanced because God is in the equation.
In fact, God can set so many of our
selfish rituals straight.
How many people are linked to each other
by selfish ties that the one may not do
this or that or the other because the
other one restrains him. Now if you have
the spirit of God in you, you become
selfless and your whole view changes and
you want to make the other one more
happy by giving more and more freedom
and of course that is dangerous in the
eyes of the world because freedom means
you can do what you want to. So it's a
question of choice. So if you are making
your choices within the realms of what
God has defined as right and good, then
the relationship can blossom. It's
absolutely amazing. So here God says
that you must keep the Sabbath day for
in six days the Lord made the heavens,
the earth, the sea, and all that is in
them. But is he's the creator. He's the
one that brought it all about. And he
rested on the seventh day. He rested.
Was God tired?
>> No.
>> No. God wasn't tired. So, what is this
rest that he found in his relationship
with man?
He rested because in man, he found the
fulfillment of his whole plan for the
entire universe. His whole plan in man
was to be made manifest the glory of
God. He created man for his own glory,
says the Bible. In other words, man was
to reflect to the universe the glory and
the wisdom of God. It's a noble, noble
purpose. Tremendous thoughts. So here,
God looked at this new creation of his
and he found rest in it. It's it's like
when you have a new relationship.
You've met this woman of your dreams, or
if you are of the opposite sex, this man
of your dreams,
and you've been separated for a while,
and now you come together again for the
first time, and you look at each other,
and you hold each other, and you have
nothing to say
except
rest. To find rest in the relationship.
Does that make any sense? So God rested.
He found peace in the relationship even
though he knew that war was going to
break out all around him as a
consequence because the devil was angry
when he created man. He was angry. But
God found rest in man. And man can find
rest in God in spite of what's going on
around us. So he rested on the seventh
day. Wherefore the Lord blessed the
Sabbath day and hallowed it. Do you know
that two lovers that really love each
other can find rest in each other even
if the whole world is going up in smoke
around them? Did you know that?
Absolutely. So we can only find rest in
God. So God took this Sabbath day and
set it aside for a holy purpose. He said
to man, "You go and have dominion. You
go and do whatever you want to do. You
place the world under you. Put it into
subjection. Change it. Modify it. Do
whatever you like. But once a week,
let's come and have holy communion
together. We will talk every day. We
will walk together every day. We will
commune every day. But let's set a day
aside." That's what it is all about.
Exodus 20:1. For in six days the Lord
made the heavens and the earth, the sea,
and all the in them, and he rested. And
the Hebrew word used there is no,
whereas previously it was Shabbat,
the seventh day. Wherefore the Lord
blessed the Sabbath day, and he
hallowed. And this new, if you look it
up in the Strong's concordance,
means to rest, to settle down. It means
to be confederate.
It's like I've been explaining to be
together to have this feeling that wow
this is great we belong together.
Moreover
also I gave them my Sabbaths to be a
sign between me and them that they may
know that I am the Lord that sanctify
them. This holy relationship, this
capacity to do what is right, this will
to do what is right comes from God. And
so the Lord gave the Sabbath as a sign
between them that they may know that he,
the Lord, is the one that sanctifies
them. Ex Ezekiel 20 12 and 20. So here's
another parallel text. And hallow my
Sabbaths. Hallow them. And there shall
be a sign between me and you, that you
may know that I am the Lord your God.
This is weird. Is it possible that
somebody else could be the Lord your
God? Yes or no?
>> Yes. Well, many people, the ancient
folks, even the Israelites, constantly
strayed and bowed down to another deity,
whoever he was, whether he was Malik or
whether he was Bal or whether he was
whatever, or they worshiped Ashtto, the
queen of heaven,
all these strange deities, God says,
"No, no, no, listen here. I make a pact
with you. Hallow my Sabbath, and it
shall be a sign between me and you, that
you may know that I am the Lord your
God. It's like a test. It's like a test.
Exodus 31:13,
"Speak thou also unto the children of
Israel, saying, verily my Sabbath ye
shall keep, for it is a sign between me
and you throughout your generations,
that you may know that I am the Lord
that does sanctify you, not another, I
am the one." Exodus 31:16, "Wherefore
the children of Israel shall keep the
Sabbath, to observe the Sabbath
throughout their generation, for a
perpetual covenant."
for a perpetual covenant. Now, let's
have a look at this sign.
It is a sign.
Hebrews, the word there is oath, between
me and the children of Israel forever.
Why? For in six days the Lord made the
heavens and the earth and rested on the
seventh day and he was refreshed. Nafash
very interesting verse this. So it is a
sign and why because God is your
creator. He's your owner. He says there
choose me. I the one who made you. All
the others didn't make you. They're just
stealing you and offering you nothing in
return but death. So, it is a sign and
God was refreshed. Now, what does that
word sign mean? Well, if you look up the
Hebrew again, put it into your strongest
concordance. You can do this all at home
if you have a computer, if you have a
concordance, look it up, and it says it
is a token. It is an enzyme. It is a
miracle if you like. And it is a mark.
It is a standard. It is a mark,
a signal, a distinguishing mark. That's
the Strong's concordance definition of
the word. So, does God have a mark?
>> Yes.
>> What is it?
>> Sabbath.
>> It's the Sabbath. God has a mark. Does
the beast have a mark?
>> Yeah. It's called the mark of the beast.
I wonder what that is. Is it a computer
in Brussels?
Is it a barcode that will be chapped
onto your hand? Is it something that you
find on a can of beans if you look at
the bottom?
Is God interested in lines on a can of
beans or is he interested in your
character and in your allegiance?
What is he interested in?
>> In your character and in your
allegiance. So let's have a look at this
very carefully. All right. So we've now
established that God has a mark, a sign,
and it is the Sabbath.
So it is a mark or a sign between me and
the children of Israel forever. For in
six days the Lord made the heavens and
the earth and the seventh day he rested
and he was refreshed. So we must
understand God's mark, his sign or his
seal. These are synonyms.
Let's have a look at the seal of the
United States. Seeing that we are in the
United States, a seal authenticates a
document. This is the seal of the
president of the United States of
America. And this was a typical royal
seal. This was the seal of George V 6,
regent king of England. Note the three
elements. It gives his name, George V 6,
and it gives his title, which is king,
and it gives his territory, which is
Great Britain and the Dominions. So a
typical seal has all those components.
The title and it has the name and it has
the territory and without it a law would
be useless. It would have no authority.
Now the decalogue is a law. It is the
law of God. Now this whole law has its
authority
only because it has a seal in it. And
the Lord delivered to me two tablets of
stone written with the finger of God.
Deuteronomy 9 verse 10. God's seal is in
the heart of God's law. Let's listen to
this carefully. All the other
commandments are just commandments. Thou
shalt not kill. Thou shalt not do this.
Thou shalt not do that. Thou shalt not
have another god besides me. Thou shalt
not use the name in vain. Honor your
parents and your and you will have a
long life, etc. But here there's
something special. Remember the Sabbath
day to keep it holy. Six days shall you
labor and do all your work. But the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
your God. For in six days the Lord,
there's the name. That's Yave. That's
God's name. We have a name. He made the
heavens and the earth. So that is the
title. He's the creator. And what is the
dominion? Heaven, earth, sea, all that
is in them. So there you have the
dominion. All the elements are there.
And without the Sabbath, the law would
have no authenticity. It would be just
another document. But now it has the
stamp of God, Yave, your creator,
dominion. Heaven, earth, sea,
everything, every nation, everything
that was ever created is under my
dominion.
Now, if the United States makes a law, a
new law, and proclaims a new law, then
that law must be signed by whom before
it comes into effect?
>> The president.
>> The president must sign it. And if a
president doesn't sign it, the law is
not valid. Is that right? All right.
Now, imagine I always use a parable to
explain this.
Imagine we place ourselves back sometime
there in the times of Germany and Adolf
Hitler
comes to power and he's so impressed
with his power, he wants to make sure
that there is no opposition.
So he proclaims a law. It's just a
hypothetical story. It's a nonsense
story, but it's just there to illustrate
a point. He proclaims a law and he says,
"Next Wednesday 12:00,
I want the German people to come onto
the streets and proclaim their
solidarity for me by one voice shouting
hitler on that particular day on
Wednesday at whatever time 12:00 1:00
let's say 12:00 everybody has to do it
and the Gestapo is out and the military
police is out and the parades are full.
How many of the German people would have
appeared on the street that day?
>> Just about everybody. And there they go.
And when the clock strikes, they all
show their solidarity.
Now,
I was so impressed with that that I make
a law. And I said, "No, no, no, no. Next
Thursday at 12:00, everybody has to come
onto the street and shout hy walter
fight. Send that out to everyone in
Germany. Next Thursday comes around, how
many people appear on the streets?
>> Not one single sausage.
That's not fair. Why not? Why they do it
for that bozo but not for me?
What's the difference?
I don't have the authority. I don't have
the title. I don't have the
jurisdiction. Does that make sense? So
his counts, Mine's counts for nothing.
Mine counts for nothing. I have the same
law, but it means nothing. Well, Adolf
Hitler got so excited when he got such a
positive response. It never happened, by
the way. But he decides to write the
same law and he sends it, let's say, to
Russia and says, "Next Wednesday 12:00,
I want the Russian people on the roads
and shouting the same thing." How many
Russians would appear on the streets?
Not one. Maybe they would appear to mock
him. What's the difference? Why did it
work in Germany and not in Russia?
>> He didn't have the jurisdiction. He
might have had a title and he might have
had all those things but he didn't have
the jurisdiction. So here we have all of
these in one shot. The Lord that's his
name. We have the jurisdiction. We have
the title the creator and we have the
jurisdiction which includes everything
on earth and in heaven. So everybody has
to obey him. This makes the law
authentic and gives power to the whole
of the law. Without the Sabbath, without
that signature, the whole law becomes
just another document with rules. Not
saying where it comes from, not saying
who has the authority. So the Lord, the
creator, heaven and earth, that is what
authenticates the whole law. Everybody
understand that? Without it, the law is
not authenticated.
So this seal contains his name, his
title, and his territory. Moreover, I
gave them my Sabbath to be a sign
between me and them, that they may know
that I am the Lord that sanctified them.
So now, how do I show God that I am
willing to obey him?
Do I put up a big banner? Do I wear a
certain dress? Do I put a certain hat on
my head? Do I do whatever? Or do I just
obey him
>> and keep that day because he said so?
Isn't that the greatest sign of all if
you just do it because he said so?
Wow, that's fantastic. Now, what if
somebody else comes along and says,
"Now, hang on a second. Hang on a
second. What's going on here? Who do you
think you are
obeying that precept and giving your
allegiance to that power?" I'm telling
you, I don't want you to obey them. I
want you to obey me. And I'm telling
you, let's change this. Let's check who
has authority in your life.
Is it God or is it me? And I'm telling
you, you better obey me rather than God.
Would you have a problem?
>> Sure you'd have a problem. I always use
another parable. Par parable.
I always tell the story of let's say for
example, again, this is totally
hypothetical, right? It's a nice
parable. I always use it and everybody
always misunderstands it and they think
it's really true but it's not true. It's
just a parable. Assume I'm married to my
wife many years and I have children and
then one day some other bozo comes
along. Is that an acceptable word in
this country? I don't know. He comes
along and he gets my wife to follow him
and she leaves me and moves in with this
other guy. Marries him and takes the
kids with him.
Now I'm
devastated. Devastated. There she is
with this other guy. And why she wants
to choose this guy with the cauliflower
ears and the buck teeth in the first
place, I don't know. But she's off with
him and she's left me. And now I had
certain rules in my house. Let's say the
kids have to be in bed at a certain time
or they have to do their homework or
they have to help in the house and
they're not allowed to watch bad stuff
on television. And if they go out, they
have to be back at a reasonable time.
Stuff like that, normal stuff.
And this new guy says to the kids when
they move in, listen, in this house, I'm
the authority in your lives as far as
this house is concerned. And I want you
to keep your, you know, live tidily and
help in the house and not to be too late
when you come home and and uh, you know,
all the good things that I had as well.
Would I have a problem with any of those
rules that he made? Yes or no?
>> No. I would have no problem with them
whatsoever. But then he has one extra
rule and he says to my kids, "Listen, I
have one extra rule. Your dad has had
authority over you in the past. Your dad
had authority over you in the past, but
that is over. I am the new authority in
your life, and you will obey me." And
the kids say, "Hang on a second. We have
visitation times with my dad on certain
days. He only has that particular day
which he has specified cuz it's the
right one or whatever." And this guy
says, "No way. You will listen to me, no
longer to your dad." Would I have a
problem with that rule?
>> Yeah. I probably go around and modify
his nose by turning it around 360° right
now. Why does that rule irritate me?
because it affects my authority. Nobody
messes with my authority when it comes
to my kids. They're my kids, too.
They're my kids, too. Now, God feels the
same way. We are his kids. And another
power comes along and says, "I don't
care about these other rules, but this
particular one, the one that tests
authority, you will obey me and not
God." Hey, God says, "I'll turn your
nose around 360° whether you like it or
not."
>> And he will. and he will. It's going to
happen. So God says, "I gave them my
Sabbath to be a sign between me and them
that they may know that I am the Lord
that sanctifies them." Isaiah 58:13
says, "If you turn away thy foot from
the Sabbath, from doing thy pleasure on
my holy day, and call the Sabbath a
delight."
I'm not talking about the way the Jews
kept the Sabbath. A ritual where you do
this and you're not allowed to do that
and you're not allowed to eat an egg
that was laid on the Sabbath and you're
not allowed to do this, that, and the
other, walk so many yards or whatever.
No, no, no, no. That's a burden. It says
here he called the Sabbath a delight,
not the burden.
the holy of the Lord, honorable, and
shall honor him, and not doing thine own
ways, nor finding thine own pleasure,
nor speaking thine own words. Then shalt
thou delight thyelves in the Lord, and I
will cause you to ride upon the high
places of the of the earth, and feed
thee with the heritage of Jacob thy
father, for the mouth of the Lord has
spoken it. He says, "If you honor my
authority in your life and you spend it
with me and you allow me to sanctify
you, you will you will be happy and you
will have the heritage of Jacob, which
is eternal life."
And what about the strangers? Did it
apply only to the Jews this Sabbath day?
Isaiah 56:6 and 7. all the sons of the
stranger that joined themselves to the
Lord to serve him and to love the name
of the Lord, to be his servants.
Everyone that keeps the Sabbath. The
Sabbath became the sign of your
allegiance to the deity called Yave. It
was the sign. Even them will I bring to
my holy mountain and make them joyful in
my house of prayer. For mine house shall
be called a house of prayer for all
people. So if a stranger came,
did he have to accept the Sabbath? Yes
or no?
>> Yes.
>> Sure. He had to accept the Sabbath.
Deuteronomy 11:13-20. And it will be for
you if you will listen carefully to my
commandments which I command you today.
Take heed to yourselves that your heart
may not be deceived.
The commandments are the law. They're
rigid. You cannot change them. and you
turn aside and serve other gods and
worship them. So, is there a possibility
that this conflict could arise? Yes or
no? Certainly could.
Therefore, now listen carefully. You
shall lay up these my words in your
hearts talking about the commandments of
God and in your souls and bind them for
a sign
upon your hand. Listen carefully now. on
your hand so that they may may be as
frontlets between your eyes. So where
must the commandments of God be placed?
On your hand and in your forehead. Wow.
Is there a mark of a beast that must be
placed on the hand or the forehead? Yes
or no?
>> Oh, but the commandments of God must be
on your hand on your forehead. Now, the
Jews were very clever. They wrote out
the ten commandments on a little plaque
and stuck them on the hand and stuck
them on the forest and there the deed
was done.
I've got the law in my hand. I've got
the law in my forest. Big deal. You
think what God had in mind? That would
be so silly. It would be unbelievable.
God never had that in mind. What did he
have in mind when he said that?
He said, "Tie them to your hand. Act
accordingly.
put them in there. Think accordingly.
Doesn't that make sense? It's got
nothing to do with an outward sign. God
is not silly.
And these words which I command you this
day shall be in your heart.
That's where he wanted them. I wonder
whether they cut it open over here and
put the plaque inside there as well. No,
they didn't.
And you shall carefully teach them to
your sons, and you shall bind them for a
sign upon your hand, and they shall be
as frontlets between your eyes here in
your cognitive thinking. This is God's
law. I will keep God's law. He is my
God. I will follow him. That's what it
says.
Continue in Exodus 13:9. It shall be a
sign unto them upon thine hand
and for a memorial between thine eyes
that the Lord's law may be in thy mouth.
It's pretty clear what must be on the
forehead and on the hand. The law of
God. It's got nothing to do with a
barcode from a can of beans or whatever.
It's got to do with the law of God that
has to be on your hand and that has to
be in your forehead. Now, what about
that other guy with the cauliflower ears
and the buck teeth who takes away the
followers of God? Actually, he doesn't
have cauliflower ears and buck teeth.
He's actually quite handsome. It's quite
irritating. But in any case, takes them
away and misleads them. Misleads them.
And he says, "No, no, no, no, no. My
sign, my mark on your forehead or your
hand." Well, let's have a look. What was
the purpose then of the Sabbath? It was
a day of rest. It was a day of blessing.
It was a day of peace. It was a sign. It
was a memorial to creation.
It was a symbol of sanctification.
It was a hallowed day. And it was a
perpetual covenant. That was what there
was. And remember Mark 2 verse 27, the
Sabbath was made for man and not man for
the Sabbath. That doesn't get rid of the
Sabbath. It just tells you that man
needs the Sabbath. Man needs this
communication with his God and he must
know who his God is. The God that we
serve is the God of the Sabbath. That's
the God whom we serve. Otherwise, who is
he? Is it the one of the Friday? Is it
the one of the Sunday? Is it the one of
the Wednesday? Is it a god of the
Hindus? Is it the one of Buddhists? Is
it the one of the Shintus? Is it this
one? Is it that one? I'll tell you what,
it's the God of the Sabbath. Simple as
that. That's what the Bible says.
Oh, that thou hearkened unto my
commandments, then had peace then had
thy peace been as a river, and thy
righteousness as the waves of the sea.
Isaiah 48:18. You would know exactly
where you stand, where you are.
Deuteronomy 5:29. Oh, that there was
such a heart in them that they would
fear me and keep all my commandments.
Nine of them or all of them?
>> All of them? All my commandments always,
that it might be well with them and with
their children forever.
Well, having established that, then why
do we keep Sunday?
Why don't we keep the Sabbath? Why does
the Christian world keep Sunday?
Sunday? Let's ask Webster's
international dictionary what it means.
Some of the new diction dictionaries get
quite sneaky. You got to watch it. In
the old days, they used to define it
like this. So-called because this day
was anciently dedicated to the sun or
its worship.
Chef's encyclopedia says Sunday, dear
solace of the Roman calendar, day of the
sun being dedicated to the sun, the
first day of the week. Most Oxford
dictionaries will say Sunday, first day
of the week. New Oxford dictionaries
will say Sunday day following Saturday.
That's pathetic. That's not a definition
anymore. That's a definition in terms of
another definition. Doesn't mean
anything anymore. But there you have it.
That's what it is. It's the day of the
sun. It's dear solace of the Roman
calendar. The day of the sun. And it's
the first day of the week. It's not the
seventh day of the week.
Sabbath, a Hebrew word signifying rest.
Sunday was a name given by the heathens
to the first day of the week because it
was the day on which they worshiped the
sun. John Edi, a Bible encyclopedia,
page 561. You can check it out. I mean,
it's all there. The reference are there.
Take your ordinary dictionary at home
and see what that says. So, the Sabbath
is not Sunday. It's Saturday. Sunday is
the first day of the week, but the
Christian world keeps Sunday. Let's have
a look at a at a photocopy if you like a
photograph of a of a dictionary. Seventh
day. Saturday. The seventh day of the
week. Saturday. The seventh day of the
week. Daniel 7:25 remember said, "And
he, the little horn, who identified him
last night, shall speak words against
the most high shall work wear out the
saints of the most high and plot to
change times and laws, and they shall be
given into his hand until a time, times,
and a half a time." Now, Revelation 13:7
talks about this beast that has all the
attributes of the little horn. And we've
already said if it looks like a duck and
walks like a duck and quacks like a
duck, then it's probably a duck. So this
beast is exactly the same power as the
little horn power. And we are told that
this beast will implement with the aid
of another power which we will deal with
tomorrow night. The mark of this beast.
Now we've already established what God's
mark was. What was it?
>> The Sabbath. And where was it to be
written?
on the forehead and on the hand. Now it
was given unto him to make war with the
saints and to overcome them. And the
power was given him over all kindreds
and tongues and nations. Revelation
13:7.
And he causes all, both small and great,
rich and poor, free and bond, to receive
a mark in their right hand or in their
foreheads.
and that no man might buy or sell save
he that had the mark or the name of the
beast or the number of his name.
Fascinating text. Fascinating text. We
will deal with this in detail and take
it apart. Every aspect of that text we
will open up. One little difference
between God's mark and the beast marks.
And it's just a tiny little difference.
It lies over here. It says,
"All both small and great, rich and
poor, free and bond, to receive a mark
in their right hand
or
in their foreheads." God's was to be in
the right hand
>> and in the forehead. God is not
satisfied with halfway service. All or
nothing. This beast is happy if you have
it in your forehead. That is, you think
it's right and you act accordingly. But
he's also happy if you don't think it's
right. If you go along with it because
you have no other choice. So act
accordingly because he said so, then
he's also will leave you alone. Does
that make sense? As long as you obey
him. He doesn't care how, whether you're
convinced or not, as long as you obey
him. Wow.
And if you don't do it, economic
boycott, you will not be able to buy or
sell. We'll freeze your bank account.
We'll freeze it and save that you have
this mark or the name of the beast
stands for its character or the number
and we'll be dealing with that as well.
Now, let's have a look at the Roman
decalia.
Now, this comes from a Roman Catholic
source decret translat.
He, the Pope, can pronounce sentences
and judgments in contradictions to the
rights of nations, to the law of God and
man. He's a mighty man. He's mightier
than God or any nation on earth. He can
free himself from the commands of the
apostles, he being their superior, and
from the rules of the Old Testament. He
can do whatever he likes.
We read further, the pope has the power
to change times, to abregate laws, and
to dispense with all things even the
precepts of Christ. So no matter what
the old husband said, I'm the new
husband around here. You won't listen to
your previous dad. You'll listen to me.
Have we got this other guy around? Yes
or no?
>> Yes,
>> we have him around. There he is. Let's
see what he says. 2 Thessalonians 2:34.
Let no man deceive you by any means, for
that day shall not come except there
come a falling away first. And that man
of sin which is transgressing of the law
will be revealed. The son of pition who
opposes and exaltth himself above all
that is called God. He's the other guy.
And these days coming when his nose will
be twisted 360 degrees, not by me or by
any man but by God without human hands.
The Bible says
Pope Nicholas quoted in facts for the
time Pope the Pope's will stands for
reason. He can dispense above the law
and of wrong make right by correcting
and changing laws. He's a powerful guy.
He can do whatever he likes.
Ask the Catholic Church which is the
Sabbath day. It says Saturday is the
Sabbath day. Your dad said keep
Saturday, but I'm telling you no
visitation on that day. Then why do you
observe Sunday instead of Saturday? Why?
Because I'm the new authority in your
life and we observe Sunday instead of
Saturday because we the Catholic Church
transferred the somnity from Saturday to
Sunday. This is not just any source.
This is the converts catechism of
Catholic doctrine 1957.
That's pretty straight out of the
horse's mouth. This is the new
boyfriend.
And he says, "You will not listen to
your dad. you'll listen to me because I
said so. So what is he attacking?
Isn't he attacking the authority of God?
You cannot attack the authority of God
of God on the strength of any other
commandment except the Sabbath. You can
only attack the authority of God on the
strength of the Sabbath because that is
what determines the authority. So what
is the mark of the beast then? We have a
beast. We have a beast that says you
will accept my mark and you will have it
on your hand or your forehead. We have a
seal of God which is a mark which says
you will keep the commandments of God on
your hands and on your foreheads. Whoa.
We're coming to an impass. There's no
compromise here. What does the beast
say? What is its mark? This is the
Catholic record. September 1, 1923. They
say Sunday is our mark of authority.
So what is the mark of the beast then?
What does it say? It says Sunday. The
church is above the Bible. Wow. I'm the
new boyfriend. You don't listen to the
rules of your dad. You listen to me.
And this transference of Sabbath
observance is proof of that fact.
Catholic record. There they say it. So
we have two marks on this earth. And the
choice is ours. Either we obey God or we
obey the new boyfriend. That's it.
So, Satan has attacked the Sabbath
because it is the seal of God. It
affects the authority of God. Let's have
some more quotes. Catholic world, March
1894. She took the pagan Sunday and made
it the Christian Sunday and thus the
pagan Sunday dedicated to Bala. That's
Bal
became the Christian Sunday sacred to
Jesus.
Interesting.
Let's take another one. Faith of our
fathers. Cardinal Gibbons. Of course,
the Catholic Church claims that the
change was her act and the act and he
reiterates it is a mark of her
ecclesiastical power. She says she's
mightier than God in this issue. I don't
care what laws God made. You will listen
to me. This is real arrogance.
The Bible says, "Remember that thou keep
holy the Sabbath day." The Catholic
Church says, "No,
they're pretty straight." Who's this
speaking? Oh, it's Father Enright
writing in the American Sentinel. This
is the Catholic Church spokesman. He
says, "The Bible says so, but the
Catholic Church says, "No,
by my divine power, I abolish the
Sabbath day and command you to keep holy
the first day of the week." And lo, the
entire civilized world bows down in
reverent obedience to the command of the
Holy Catholic Church.
Isn't that arrogance beyond measure?
It is so arrogant. Freaks me out. by my
divine power. Well, if that's their
divine power, then it must be a
different divine power to God's divine
power. Right or wrong?
>> There's another God on earth who sets
himself up in the temple of God claiming
to be God. So, we have two that we are
serving. Of course, the Catholic Church
is not really God. It must have another
power behind it. And the Bible says,
"And the dragon gave him his seat and
power and great authority." Those are
very sad words and I don't say them
flippantly. Catechismos Ramanos Pope
Pius 1566 commanded by the council of
Trent. It pleased the church of God that
the religious celebration of the Sabbath
day should be transferred to the Lord's
day, Sunday. Over and over they say, I
was in a spirit on the Lord's day.
Revelation 1:10, they say, "Well, the
Lord's day was Sunday." It doesn't say
so. It says, "I was in the spirit on the
Lord's day." It doesn't say what day it
was. Only the Bible can say which is the
Lord's day. And there it is. Isaiah
58:13. If thou turn thy foot away from
the Sabbath, from doing thy pleasure on
my holy day, and call the Sabbath a
delight, the holy of the Lord. So which
is the Lord's day according to the
Bible?
>> The Sabbath, not Sunday.
So I was in the spirit on the Lord's
day. It doesn't really cut any ice. What
about this one? Therefore, the son of
man is lord also of the Sabbath. Does
that do away with the Sabbath or
established who is in authority when it
comes to the Sabbath? By the way, who
created this world?
>> Was it the father or was it through the
son?
>> Through the son.
>> It was through the son. You go and read
John chapter one. In the beginning was
the word and the word was with God and
the word was God.
Everything that was created on this
world was created through him and for
him. By his word it stands. So Jesus is
Lord of the Sabbath.
Catholic Press, Sydney, August 25, 1900.
Sunday is a Catholic institution and its
claims to observance can be defended
only on Catholic principles. These are
all Catholic quotes. From the beginning
to the end of scriptures, there is not a
single passage which warrants the
transfer of the weekly public worship
from the last day of the week to the
first. They are so straightforward on
this. You may read the Bible from
Genesis to Revelation and you will not
find a single line authorizing the
sanctification of Sunday. The scriptures
enforce the religious observant of
Saturday. James Godard Kibbons the faith
of our fathers. The Catholic Church is
throwing out the gauntlet and saying
there take it or leave it. Choose
the Christian Sabbath is to this day the
acknowledged offspring of the Catholic
Church as spouse of the Holy Ghost
without a word of remmonstrance from the
Protestant world. Catholic mirror
September 23. So they say to the
Protestants, you say you're Protestants.
Why you obey us then? If you obey us,
then you're ours. Whether you like it or
not,
they're so arrogant. Chancellor of the
Arch Dascese of Baltimore replieding for
the cardinal in a letter dated 19
February 10, 1920. If Protestants would
follow the Bible, they should worship
God on the Sabbath day. In keeping the
Sunday, they are following a law of the
Catholic Church. This is the Catholic
Church speaking.
John Gibney Shay American Catholic
Quarterly Review. Protestantism in
discarding the authority of the Roman
church has no good reason for for its
Sunday theory and ought logically to
keep Saturday as the Sabbath.
Not the creator, this is really
arrogant, not the creator of the
universe in Genesis 2:1 and 3, but the
Catholic Church can claim the honor of
having granted man a pause to his work
every seven days.
This is so arrogant. It blows my mind.
quotes I've never seen.
>> This is unbelievable. And this one was
made not in the Middle Ages. This was
made in 1969.
Reason and common sense demand. And this
one should really clench it. Reason and
common sense demand acceptance of one or
the other of these alternatives. Either
Protestantism and the keeping holy of
Saturday
or Catholicity and the keeping holy of
Sunday compromise is impossible.
There you go. Catholic merit December
23, 1893. There's the battle line. If
you obey God, you keep which day?
>> Saturday.
>> Saturday. If you obey the Catholic
Church, you keep Sunday. That's what
they're saying. So if you're a
Protestant but you're keeping Sunday,
you're really obeying whom?
>> Pope.
>> You're obeying the Pope. That doesn't
mean that Protestants out there who have
never heard this information now have
the mark of the beast. They don't
because God is judging them according to
the light that they have. But this issue
is going to become prominent very very
soon because the present pope the
present pope has asked for worldwide
Sunday legislation
and your president had said we want to
implement his teachings.
That's interesting. I'll show it to you
still. I'll show it to you. So now why
do Protestants keep on keeping Sunday?
Well, what do they say? Do they know
this or don't they know this? Yes, they
know it. Yes, they know it. Let's have a
run through them quickly. The Episcopals
say, "Is there any commandment in the
New Testament to change the day of
weekly rest from Saturday to Sunday?"
None. Manual of Christian doctrine.
That's well, that's their their big
writing. We have made a change from
seventh day to the first day, from
Saturday to Sunday on the authority of
the one holy, catholic, and apostolic
church of Christ. Why we keep Sunday?
That's the episcopal church. Well,
they're so near to the Catholics. It's,
you know, it's just sort of a a hiccup
between them, but they say they know,
but they keep Sunday. All right. What
about the other Protestant groups? The
Lutheran Church, we observe the Lord's
day, Sunday, is founded or the
observance of the Lord's day, Sunday, is
founded not on any command of God, but
on the authority of the church. This is
the Also confession. And this is the
central document for Lutheranism in the
Catholic Sabbath manual part two section
one. They know it.
All right. What about the Presbyterians?
A change of the day to be observed from
the last day of the week to the first.
There is no record, no express command
authorizing the change. This is the
Christian chab Sabbath in El Rice, one
of their spokespersons. Fine. What about
the Methodists? Take the matter of
Sunday. There's no passage telling
Christians to keep that day or to
transfer the Jewish Sabbath to that day.
Christian advocate, July 2, 1942. So the
Methodists know it. Well, what's going
on here? What about the
congregationalists? It's quite clear
that however rigidly or devoutly we
spend Sunday, we are not keeping the
Sabbath. There's not a single sentence
in the New Testament to suggest that we
incur any penalt penalty by violating
the supposed sanctity of Sunday. This is
the ten commandments by Dr. Dale. All
right, that's the congregationalists. Is
there anybody out there? Hello,
Anglicans.
Many people think that Sunday is the
Sabbath. But neither in the New
Testament nor in the early church is
there anything to suggest that we have
any right to transfer the observance of
the seventh day of the week to the
first. The Sabbath was and Saturday, not
Sunday. Reverend Lionel Beer, Church of
the People. There we go. Well, what
about the Baptists?
There was and is a commandment to keep
holy the Sabbath day, but that Sabbath
was not Sunday.
There is no scriptural evidence of the
change of the Sabbath institution from
the seventh day to the first day of the
week. Is this anybody speaking? Oh no,
this is Hicks H. Scott. He's the author
of the Baptist manual. He should know.
So they all know. Every single one of
them knows. Here's another one. Reverend
Philip Carton, Arington Bishop, Quebec.
He sent them all in a scurry saying
outright that there was nothing to
support Sunday being kept holing. He
definitely told the church meeting in
the city of straightlaced Protestantism
that tradition not the Bible had made
Sunday the day of worship. Toronto Daily
Star. So tradition,
pagan tradition introduced by Rome kept
it. Now what does the Lord say about
tradition? Well, let's read that. Almost
all churches throughout the world
celebrate the sacred mysteries, the
Lord's supper on the Sabbath of every
week. Yet the Christians and now not
this of Alexandria
and at Rome on account of some ancient
tradition have ceased to do this. This
is ecclesiastical history. Now
Alexandria is the one where all the
pagan doctrines were introduced. This is
where the Sadducees learned that there
was no resurrection but that when you go
to heaven, you go and sit on Abraham's
lap.
And Jesus said, "Hey, why are you
teaching there? There's no such thing.
So Alexandria and Rome are the seat of
paganism.
Alexandria taught ancient Egyptian
gnostic mysteries
and based on cabalism andnosticism.
Ancient tradition.
Well, Catholic record says Sunday is
founded not on scripture but on
tradition and is a distinctly Catholic
institution. We will deal with that in
some astounding detail. What paganism
has done and how occultism has
controlled some of these decisions. The
New Testament makes no explicit mention
that the apostle changed the day of
worship. But we know it from tradition.
This is the revised Baltimore Catechism.
So these are the authorative documents
of the church. It's all based on
tradition. And the Bible says Matthew 15
3:6 and 9. He answered and said to them,
"Why do you transgress the commandment
of God by your tradition?
And you voided the commandments of God
by your tradition, but in vain they
worship me, teaching for doctrines the
commandments of men." Can you do it? Yes
or no? No, you can't. You cannot
substitute tradition for obedience.
These people honor me with their lips,
but their hearts are far from me. They
worship me in vain. Their teachings are
but rules taught by men. And he said to
them, you have a fine way of setting
aside the commands of God in order to
observe your own traditions. Marks 7
and9.
So the Bible says one thing, the Rome
says another. And here we have a basis
for conflict. And this basis for
conflict is going to rise like a
mushroom and it's going to come to a
head very very soon. The authority of
the church could therefore not be bound
by the authority of the scriptures
because the church had changed the
Sabbath into Sunday not by the command
of Christ but by its own authority.
Canon and tradition page 263. That's it.
That's a choice whether we like it or
whether we don't. Acts 20 says, "For I
know this that after my departure
grievous wolves come in and change the
doctrines." All right.
If you go to your churches and you ask
them why do we keep Sunday, then there
is a scurry and a flurry
and then there will be some scriptural
evidence brought forward. Although all
the authoritative writers have said
there is no scriptural authority for the
transfer, yet they will tell you there
are texts in the Bible which said that
they worshiped on the first day of the
week and therefore we worship on the
first day of the week. Or they will say
that Jesus abolished the Sabbath and
nailed it to the cross and we no longer
keep it. Therefore, let no one judge you
as to a Sabbath day quoting Colossians
and all those texts. Or they will say to
you, "How do we know what the Sabbath
is? You know, there's been so much time
and then it really doesn't matter.
Observe any day.
>> What day did God say you must observe?
>> The Sabbath day. Imagine you have a
rendevu with your loved one that you
haven't seen for a long time and she
says, "Wednesday morning 7:00 I arrive.
Please pick me up at the station."
And you think, "Okay, that's all right.
I love her. I'll go on Thursday."
Do you think she'll be happy?
>> Kind of doubt.
>> I kind of doubt it. All right. Thank
you.
The first day of the week. Let's have a
look at these texts that are used to
substantiate Sunday observance. The
first text we find in Matthew 28:1. It
says there are eight texts about the
first day of the week that are used. The
first one says in the end of the Sabbath
it became began to dawn towards the
first day of the week came Mary
Magdalene and the other Mary to see the
seleure and that's it. Is there anything
about a change of the Sabbath? Yes or
no?
>> It's a purely historic statement. The
New English Bible says the Sabbath had
passed and it was daybreak on Sunday
when Mary so and so and so and so. So
it's a purely factual statement. There's
nothing in it. All right, we can discard
it. Luke 23:54 56. by the way tells us
that these women they kept the Sabbath.
They prepared spices and ointments and
rested on the Sabbath day according to
the commandment. So they knew nothing
about a change. When these women came on
the first day, it's because they didn't
go on the Sabbath day because they
rested according to the commandment. All
right. The second text we find in Mark
chapter 16 1-2. And when the Sabbath was
passed, Mary Magdalene and Mary the
mother of James and Salomi had brought
spices that they might come and anoint
them. Very early in the morning on the
first day of the week, they came to the
select the rising of the sun. Anything
about a change there? Not a word. All
right. Third text, Mark 16:9.
When Jesus was risen early on the first
day of the week, he appeared first to
Mary Magdalene out of whom he had cast
seven devils. Anything there about a
change or is it just a statement of
fact? Statement of fact. Nothing there
about to change. We can discard that
one. Fourth text. Now upon the first day
of the week, very early in the morning,
they came to the sele bringing the
spices. So that's in Luke. It's the
other gospel. He repeats the story.
Anything about a change? Nothing. So we
can discard that one. We only got four
left that we have to deal with. Fifth
one, John 20:1. The first day of the
week cometh Mary Magdalene early when it
was yet dark into the seleure, and seeth
the stone taken away from the seleure.
Anything there? Nothing. That leaves us
with three
six texts.
John 20:1 19. Then the same day at
evening being the first day of the week
when the doors were shut where the
disciples were assembled for fear of the
Jews came Jesus and stood in the midst
and says unto them, "Peace be unto you."
This one is used quite often. Aha. The
disciples came together on the first day
of the week. They were worshiping.
Doesn't say so. It says they came
together on the first day of the week
for what?
fear of the Jews.
>> You see, on the Sabbath, they knew they
were relatively safe because no Jew
would do anything. He would think he
would be breaking the Sabbath. But when
the Sabbath was over, they were quaking
in their boots.
So, it says nothing about worship. That
leaves two texts. Two texts. And these
are the hot ones.
Acts 20:7.
And upon the first day of the week, when
the disciples came together to break
bread, Paul preached unto them ready to
depart on the tomorrow and continued his
speech until midnight. Now, the New
English Bible says on Saturday night
they came together. Ah, they say, well,
here's the text which says that they
worshiped on the Sabbath day and they
had communion. They broke bread. Now,
let's analyze the se text carefully. On
the first day of the week, they came
together to break bread. When does the
first day start? At the end of the
Sabbath. What time of day was that?
>> Evening.
>> It was in the evening. So, they came
together. When the first day of the week
came, it was evening and they came to
break bread. All right? So, that's one
text we have to look at. They came to
break bread, but Paul preached to them
ready to depart on the tomorrow. So when
the light should dawn, it would still be
which day?
>> Sunday.
>> Sunday, the first day. And he was going
to go a long, long way. And he talked to
them until midnight. Poor old Uticus was
sitting there in the window. And Paul
was probably going on and on
fell out the window. Remember the story?
And Paul had to rush down and prayed
over him and he got up. So this was not
a Sunday morning meeting. This was a
evening meeting, but it wasn't held on
the Sabbath because the Sabbath was
holy. They came together after the
Sabbath. Paul had a lot to tell them.
And if Sunday was so holy, why was Paul
going to watch the next day many, many
kilometers on the so-called holy Sunday?
No, no, no. So, we only have one thing
still to deal with. The breaking of the
bread. Let's make sure that it was in
the evening. We read further in Acts
28:11. There were many lights in the
upper chambers where they were gathered
together. So it was dark, right? And it
couldn't have been Sunday evening
because that would have been the second
day of the week. So they came together
after the Sabbath. When he therefore
came up again and had broken bread and
eaten, he talked a long while, even till
break of day. So he departed. So he even
stayed longer and talked and then when
it was daylight off he went. So it
wasn't a holy day for him at all. He was
going to go away and that's the only
time he had with a meeting for them. Now
as for the other bit the breaking of the
bread. Acts 2:46 says and they continued
what does it say there?
>> Daily with one accord in the temple
breaking bread from house to house did
they eat their meat with gladness and
singleness of heart. So they didn't have
a communion. They had
supper together. That's what it was. So
we have one text left. One text left. So
in fact this text, this pre one,
previous one supports the sanctity of
the Sabbath because only after the
Sabbath did they get together to discuss
issues and then off they went. Eight
text 1 Corinthians 16:1 and2.
Now concerning the collection for the
saints. Ah yes, they held church
collection.
As I have given order to the churches of
Galatia, even so you do. Upon the first
day of the week, let every one of you
lay by him in store. By the way, by the
way, the Weimoth translation brings it
out nicely. It says, "Lay by at home
as God has prospered him that there be
no gathering when I come." So the
critics will say, well, they held a
collection during the service in church.
No, no, no. The text refers to a putting
aside of the money on the first day of
the week at home. Now, let's think about
that. In the old days, like with many
people that still work today that earn
their money money on a weekly basis,
when is payday on a weekly basis?
Friday. Friday you get your pay. The
work is over. You get your pay. Now you
take your money and you take it home.
But in the mindset of the Hebrew, Friday
is the preparation. You're getting ready
for the Sabbath. Paul says, "Put your
money aside when?" On the
>> first day of the week.
>> First day of the week. The logical thing
is to come home to work it all out. Put
aside your your offering and your tithe
and whatever you want to put aside. Paul
says, "No, don't do it on the Friday
when you get your money. The Sabbath is
coming. The Sabbath is holy. Do it early
on the first day of the week after the
Sabbath. So when the Sabbath is over,
after Sunday, you go and sit down, put
aside your money so you don't use it
during the next week and then keep it
there until it can be collected. So does
it help Sunday worship or does it help
Sabbath worship?" this text,
it's actually for Sabbath worship. The
Sabbath is so holy, do it on the first
day of the week. So, none of those texts
did it. So, did Jesus change the
Sabbath? Luke 4:16. And he came to
Nazareth, where he had been brought up,
and as his custom was, he went into the
synagogue on the Sabbath day and stood
up to read. So Jesus kept the Sabbath.
Jesus said, "Not one jot or one turtle
would be removed from the law." Matthew
5:17-19.
Jesus didn't change the Sabbath. For
even here unto we are called, because
Christ also suffered for us, leaving us
an example, that we should follow him,
and we should walk even as he walked. 1
John 2:6. So Jesus kept the Sabbath.
There's no evidence of a change of a
Sabbath. So where's the evidence?
Malachi 3:6, I the Lord, I change not.
Jesus didn't change. Psalms 89:4, my
covenant will I not break, nor alter the
thing which has gone out of my lips. God
doesn't change.
Jesus Christ is the same yesterday,
today, and forever. Hebrews 13:8. Who
changed it? Catholic Church, not Jesus.
If you love me, then keep my
commandments. If you love them, keep
their commandments. If you keep my
commandments, you shall abide in my
love, even as I have kept my father's
commandments and abide in his love. And
he said, I know him and and he that says
I know him and keeps not his
commandments is a liar, and the truth is
not in him. That's strong words. 1 John
2:4.
That's it. You either obey God or you
don't.
For this is the love of God that we keep
his commandments
and his commandments are not grievous. 1
John 5:3.
Whosoever says that he lives in God
should live just as Jesus Christ did. He
kept the Sabbath. Christ also suffered
for us, leaving us an example. If you
love me, keep my commandments. That's
the example. Well, the Christian world
will say the cross changed the Sabbath.
No, it didn't. Let's have a look. That
day was the preparation. That was
Friday. The word preparation is just
used for that Friday, preparing for the
Sabbath. Luke 23:54.
And the women also which came from
Galilee followed beheld the seleure and
laid down his body. You remember that
story? And they returned, prepared
spices, ointment, rested on the Sabbath.
There's no change here whatsoever
according to the commandment Luke. And
they found the stone rolled rolled away
again on the first day. So the three
days of the crucifixion, you have the
preparation that was Friday. You have
the Sabbath. Jesus rested in the grave.
They rested in on that day, the the
disciples and the women. And on the
first day, things started up again. No
change. No change. So neither the the
death nor the resurrection changes it.
Can we really be sure which is the
Sabbath day? Well, what about that one?
Let's have a look what astronomy teaches
us.
Washington DC. Your letter 25 February.
We had occasion to investigate the
results and the work of specialists in
chronology and we have never found one
of them that has ever had the slightest
doubt about the continuity of the weekly
cycle since the beginning of the
Christian era and that is US Naval
Observatory Washington DC. Let's have a
look at this. People say we might have
lost the Sabbath. Well, the Sabbath was
instituted there in creation. If we lost
it, then it was reestablished at the
mana because every week the Lord made a
special miracle. On that day, the mana
lasted two days. Every other day it
lasted one day. So the Sabus if it
should have been lost was reinstated
over there. If it was lost thereafter,
it was reinstated at Mount Si. Then if
we come to 46 BC that's where the
Justinian the Julian calendar at least
was instituted. So we have absolute
continuity from then onwards and the
cross falls in there and we've just read
Jesus kept the Sabbath, the disciples
kept the Sabbath and that falls in the
Julian calendar. There's no loss over
there. Then in 1582,
there's a change of the calendar and we
move to the Gregorian calendar. Oh,
that's exciting. I like that because the
Gregorian calendar refers to whom?
>> To Pope Gregory. And Pope Gregory saw
fit to change the times.
Why? Because there was something
bothering him. But by the way, it didn't
move the Sabbath at all. We went in
October to one, two, three, four, 15
October. So we jumped a couple of days
there, but the weekly cycle was not
affected at all. So the Sabbath is
intact. It has never been lost. By the
way, why did the Pope want to move the
calendar
those days?
What bothered him? Why did he change the
times?
I'll tell you what bothered him. It
bothered him that the pash,
the Christian Pash, was not 100% in line
with the pagan feast of Ishtar,
which we still call Easter to this day.
And he wanted to shift the calendar
those few days so that the world should
keep all the pagan feasts rather than
recognize what it is in the Bible. Did
you know that there was war as a
consequence? The British decided no way
are we going along with this. There was
war as a consequence. But it was forced
upon them because we will keep the pagan
festivals. We will not obey the Bible.
These people are very arrogant. So no
day is lost. The date shifts from the
4th to the 15th, but the weekly cycle is
intact. Which day are the Jews keeping
today?
>> Saturday.
>> Saturday. Same as always. Matthew 24:20.
Pray that your flight be not in the
winter nor on the Sabbath day. Jesus is
saying 70 AD when they come to destroy
this place pray that the Sabbath day
will not be the day when you have to
flee. So he foresaw the Sabbath still
being in existence. Then one last text.
Shake your heads. Go wake up.
What about Colossians 2:16?
Wow. This one is used every time. Let no
man therefore judge you in meat or drink
or in respect of any holy day or the new
moon or the Sabbath days. That's the
King James version. Let no one judge you
regard to the Sabbath days.
Now, Sabbath days
refers to the ceremonial Sabbath days.
The Sabbath day refers to the seven week
or the 7 day week Sabbath. Let no one
therefore judge you in meat or drink or
in respect of a feast day or a new moon
or a Sabbath day. That's the American
Standard Version. All right. Which of
the Ten Commandments deals with eating
and drinking and new moons and all of
those? Any of them.
So which laws deal with eatings and
drinkings and new moons and things like
that?
>> Ceremonial.
>> The ceremonial laws blotting out the
handwriting of ordinances that was
against us which was contrary to us and
took it out of the way nailing it to the
cross. Let no man therefore judge you.
So they say Jesus nailed the Sabbath to
the cross. No, Jesus never nailed the
Sabbath to the cross. He nailed two
things to the cross. The whole of the
ceremonial law was nailed to the cross
because Jesus became the fulfillment of
the law and the condemnation of the law
was nailed to the cross but not the law
itself.
How do I know? Because it says over
there that these laws, this handwriting
of ordinances which was against us and
only the writings of Moses, the
ceremonial law were to be written in a
book placed beside the ark as a witness
says the Old Testament against us.
So these were a shadow of things to
come. But the body, the substance of
them is Christ. Colossians 2:17. So
let's quickly recap. The weekly Sabbath
was instituted in Eden, right?
Okay. And it points back to creation. It
existed before sin. There it is. It
points to creation. Hello, my Sabbath.
Keep the Sabbath. For in six days the
Lord made the heavens, the earth, the
sea, and the springs of water. It
reminds us of where we come from. the
shadow Sabbaths. In other words, the
feast of unleven bread, uh the Passover,
the feast of the wave offering, the
first fruits, all of those special
Sabbaths, they could fall on any day,
but they pointed to the ministry of
Christ.
They point forward to Christ. So the
ceremonial Sabbath
linked the sanctuary service, the shadow
service, and pointed forward forward to
redemption. So when Colossians says the
Sabbath was a shadow of things to come,
who did it point to? Christ. The
substance thereof being Christ. So when
Christ died, he nailed the ceremonial
law to the cross. We don't have to keep
special Sabbaths anymore. We don't have
to follow the rituals of the Passover,
which have to do with eating and
drinking. and how much of the Passover
you were supposed to have and all those
issues.
It deals with ceremonies, but the
Sabbath deals with creation and the ten
commandments. So those are the only
texts that are used against the Sabbath.
The disciples, did they change the
Sabbath? Paul, as his manus was,
went into them and three Sabbath days
reasoned with them out of the scriptures
talking to the Jews. And then it says,
"And he reasoned in the Sabbath with the
Jews and the Greeks. And when the Jews
were gone out of the synagogue, the
Gentiles besought that these words may
be preached to them the next Sabbath.
And the next Sabbath day almost the
whole city came together." We read that
in Acts 13:42 and 44. So Paul and the
disciples preached on a Sabbath. They
kept the Sabbath whether they were
talking to Jews or whether they were
talking to Gentiles.
So this is the bottom line. Here is the
patience of the saints. Here are they
that keep God's commandments. How many
of them?
>> All 10. And the faith of Jesus.
Revelation 14:12.
I will put my laws into their minds and
write them in my hearts. That's quoting
Hebrews 18. That's the new covenant.
The new covenant is taking the law of
God, putting it into the heart, into the
mind,
onto the hand, into the forehead, act
accordingly, think accordingly, obey
God. The Catholic Church says, "No, by
my divine authority, you will obey me
and not them." But the Bible says,
Revelation 22:14, and this is New
Testament, blessed are they that do his
commandments, that they may have the
right to the tree of life.
Aha. Obedience is going to be a test
and may enter in through the gates into
the city. And then if you're obedient,
we according to his promise look for a
new heaven and a new earth wherein
dwelleth righteousness. 2 Peter 3:13.
Nobody now has the mark of the beast.
Nobody now has it. When that law is
enforced and it's coming because the
pope has asked for it. And don't think
Islamic countries or Judeaic countries
will be excluded. The pope has asked for
it and they will keep it. When that law
comes, then the decision will be made
and you choose either the one with the
cauliflower ears and the butt teeth or
you choose the Lord. One of the two. The
Bible says, "For as the new heavens and
the new earth which I shall make shall
remain before me, says the Lord, so
shall your seed and your name remain.
And it shall come to pass that from one
new moon to another, and from one
Sabbath to another, shall all flesh come
to worship before me, says the Lord.
Isaiah 66:22:23.
This is the new world. Will the Sabbath
be kept in the new world? Yes or no?
>> Yes. What is this new moon thing doing
over here? The new moon from one new
moon to another. So on a monthly basis,
isn't the new moon festival a ceremonial
law? Is that going to be kept? Well,
there's something that will be kept on a
monthly basis in heaven as well because
the Bible says
that the tree of life bore its fruits
how many times?
>> Once a month. So, I have news for you.
Oh, yeah. And the Bible says it bore how
many manner of fruits?
>> 12 kinds of fruits. And the leaves of
the tree were for the healing of the
nations. Wow. So let's imagine this. The
tree of life will bear its fruit once a
month and we will go and we will partake
of the tree of life once a month. The
leaves maybe we make some tea, the most
delightful tea, caffeine free, of
course, from the tree of life. It's
going to be a feast, folks.
And from one Sabbath to another shall
all flesh come before the Lord, and the
righteous shall inherit the land and
dwell therein forever. Psalms 37:29.
I have condemned no one tonight, no
individual. I have not said anyone is
lost who is keeping Sunday out of
faithfulness of their hearts. At the
moment, I've said none such thing. I
have just said there is a system on this
earth that lays claim to the fact that
it stands above God, that it is higher
than God and that it has authority in
your life over and above the authority
of God. And that very soon this test
will come to a point when this authority
will be tested and your allegiance will
be on the line and you will be asked to
choose the one or to choose the other.
If you choose the one, you choose the
beast and you obtain its mark. If you
choose the other, then you will obtain
the mark or the seal of God and you will
be sealed for God. That's what it is.
Obedience does not lie in the day alone
because the Sabbath stands for how much
of the law?
>> All of it. Because the authority of the
law is based on the seal. So the Sabbath
is merely the authentication of the
whole law. We must develop Christlike
characters. We must allow the Lord to
change us. We must have a relationship
with the Lord. By keeping the law, no
one's going to be saved. By having a
relationship with God, we can be saved
and will be saved. But if we have the
right relationship with God, we will
also keep his law. That's the bottom
line. I hope that this issue is clear.
Tomorrow night, we're going to deal with
the beasts of Revelation 13. And
particularly the people of this nation
should be here. It's thunderous stuff.
Don't miss it. Thank you for coming.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.